speaking of Lamar Jackson
you know he's going through contract
which we've all been through this you
know um he's going through some type of
I don't even know what it is because I'm
on the outside looking in and I always
just try to bypass the narrative because
I was on that side too and I know like
the media they pump this type of you
know nerve to say I turned down this or
I turned down that and I don't really
like to look at that I look at it this
way
the quarterbacks before him whether it's
um DeShaun Watson whether it's Kyla Mary
where there's Patrick Mahomes you know
all these guys got paid and it's his
turn like that's just how it is it's
it's his turn he's done everything he
could possibly do to put himself up to
have a to have a great contact a
contract that um jumps all of those guns
because this is how it works you know
this guy gets paid this much and it's
just you have to carry the ball higher
and you have to do whatever it takes to
get there
um you can't take less you have to do
whatever it takes to get there to for
him
um to be out of those guys the highest
paid guy because it's just it's just a
step it's just a it's just like a how do
I say it a sliding it's like a it's just
like a little stepping stone like once
Kyler Murray went here Lamar Jackson
goes here once the Sean Watson goes here
Lamar Jackson goes right here and it's
not about uh of course it's about unfair
production Lamar has done all that he's
been MVP of the league he's done
everything for his team to get this
contract and it just baffles me whenever
we have like these uh these stalemates
between player and the team
yeah man I'll say that he's very aware
he understands what he's supposed to do
he understands like you know whatever
else is getting their bus is at he's a
smart dude you know I also think he's
confident he knows like hey man I could
play this game at a high level he knows
he's capable of doing and so he knows
that the longer it takes for the deal to
get done the more valuable the deal
becomes you know I mean the Market's
always going up salary cap goes up every
year with deception of covet you know
it's been going up I think you know
pretty much 10 a year on average for the
past you know two cbas and this next CBA
with the TV contracts we just signed
it's about to go even more crazy you
know going up so um you know I mean he
you know he's a smart man he's very
aware and he uh you know to be doing it
by himself which is rare very very rare
yeah but yeah
you know a lot of guys get nervous with
that but you know I mean well I talked
to him a little bit I don't ever try to
get in this business too much I let him
do his own thing but you know just try
to see where he was at and I could tell
that he's very uh very smart and
intellectual and he's you know he's
doing well for himself
yeah you got to get it got props he's
representing himself
um he's betting on himself
um you know he's not you know he's not
dragging this all out in the media too
you know a guy like me if you know if I
didn't get paid him I'm not playing this
[ __ ] I'm not I'm not playing this
I'm not playing this year I need my
money I did it you know and you know uh
props to Lamar man he's been very very
professional about this whole situation
you know he hasn't let it um drag him
down you know he's out there he's out
there playing he's out there with his
team you know every time they ask him
about it he kills it um I can tell that
he's a team guy playing his team first
at the same time he won against this
deal done and he's not letting it you
know affect his only field play which
that is the most important thing because
they want you to take going through the
contract negotiations they want you to
take a step back so they can point that
out like see this is why or that is why
and you know he's still continuing to
play at a high level even with all this
on his play even with all this on his
mind man and uh shout out to um Lamar
Jackson for sure